hey guys Ryan right over here hi guys
I'm Veronica so today we're gonna check
out the trailer for the gallows it's a
horror movie a lot of people especially
female subs have been asking that we
check this out and because a lot of
female soaps have been requesting it I
brought my girlfriend here today because
I wanted to establish that I am taking
ladies so back off still comment but you
know
it was a quoting
oh oh look again
cool teaser trailer I I would watch the
movie off that alone bloom house they're
like the best horror movie people around
right now they do the scariest [ __ ]
films this is a great teaser cuz it
doesn't tell you what it's about but you
really get a sense of tension and fear
the whole time I feel sorry for that
woman man I don't know what's happening
her but me too poor thing
she probably deserves it probably some
[ __ ] on Facebook err dick now she
deserves it dude that looks terrifying I
cannot watch it I can't no we're gonna
go hell no dude I can't watch this kind
of movies that looks so [ __ ] scary
red lighting and her just seen how long
did that go on for just sitting there
crying like this has been yeah it's
really tension-filled oh I missed those
kinds of horror films where the camera
just really goes on and just you feel
the suspense you feel the tension it's
not a bunch of trickery shots granted it
was just like 30 seconds but you know it
looks like it's gonna be something where
they just really let the camera roll and
you feel it through the characters the
fear that's when a scary movie is really
scary is when you're really invested in
the character and how terrified she is
it makes me think of like the first
alien movie when Sigourney Weaver's
terrified were terrified yeah we're
gonna go really yeah I'm gonna cut a
hole in the bottom of the popcorn bucket
I don't get it you guys do oh well I'm
gonna put it on my lap it looks
disgusting what does that have to do
with anything right now I just wanted to
talk about my movie theater coding
experience
that's gross why cuz I'll get butter all
over it you get your dick all over the
popcorn yeah whatever
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
veronica has a channel to posting stuff
again recently you should check it out
vlogs and covers and whatnot and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where we're constantly
posting about how much we love each
other and how great it our sex life
really is totally awesome sex life this
guy I know what I'm doing
I practice humping at all kinds of
positions let's do a shout out
throughout Drogo sh Metallica hey guys
I've recently stumbled upon your YouTube
channel and there's a lot of good stuff
in there
every day I find something great to hear
and to make me laugh no problem DRO gosh
alright dro gosh well here's your
shoutout drew gosh Metallica that's
actually a position that Veronica and I
do often mm-hmm that's where Veronica
arches her back and then I go to the
bathroom and she keeps her back arched
while I jerk off in the bathroom and
then when I'm ready to come I come out
and then right before when I'm ready to
come on her I come in my hand because I
pre ejaculated the Dro gosh Metallica
your parents don't watch this channel
today I hope to god not okay